[Musica]
[Applauso]
e
sono nato in una modesta famiglia di
campagna è lì dove le
Stelle durante le
Veglie brillano più Lucenti
e più
[Applauso]
forte il sentimento del
[Musica]
Creato fin da bambino sentivo che la
vita era più interessante in relazione e
lo si vede anche qui in questa immagine
dove ho scritto un pensierino
quando a scuola mi facevano riflettere
su questi momenti e ho scritto che
facevo mille cose Suavo La fisarmonica
recitavo dicevo poesie Ma la cosa che mi
colpisce di più è quella frase che dice
sono contento perché mi piaceva essere
in relazione fare quello che non si
vedeva fondamentalmente
L'essenziale è invisibile agli occhi
ripete il piccolo principe L'essenziale
è visibile al sentire possiamo dire
oggi e poi questa domanda ma dove trovi
il tempo io facevo mille cose non
riuscivo a star fermo e mi ricordo che
rispondevo sempre così non è il tempo è
l'energia perché pensiamoci quando
stiamo bene quando stiamo con qualcuno
che ci fa star bene l'energia si
moltiplica e il tempo trascorre c'è chi
parla di spazio
tempo e quando invece facciamo qualcosa
che non ci piace la nostra energia si
esaurisce e quindi il tempo
effettivamente dipende dall'energia
negli anni poi scrivevo nel mio
curriculum vite proprio per cercare un
lavoro un po' tutto che ero ingegnere
informatico che avevo studiato al
conservatorio facevo composizione ero
appassionato di
cosmologia facevo viaggi in Africa e e
un giorno Mi arrivò la domanda Me la
meritavo Ma tu sei ingegnere o musicista
mi chiese un capo azienda a questo
colloquio di lavoro e mi colpì molto in
quel momento quel sei Infatti io risposi
distinto di pancia Non lo so sono io
sono Entrambe le cose perché perché
sempre di
più siamo definiti in una scatola sempre
di più il nostro titolo il nostro lavoro
è un po' come una scatolina perfetta
l'ingegnere il musicista il direttore
d'orchestra il direttore
marketing però nella scatola l'uomo
muore Perché l'essere umano ha bisogno
di uscire dalla scatola di incontrare
l'altro di essere in relazione con
l'altro e infatti oggi oltre che a una
crisi energetica del pianeta Ci troviamo
di fronte a una vera e propria crisi
dell'essere umani una crisi
perché l'energia lo vedevamo prima si
riduce quando siamo
inscatolati in questo momento storico
c'è un'altra relazione che si sta
creando quella con l'intelligenza
artificiali
e sempre qui ci piace distinguerci ci
piace creare una sintesi ci piace dire
cosa va bene e cosa non va bene Io penso
che l'intelligenza umana abbia una
grandissima capacità che è quella di
essere sensibile quindi possiamo oggi
definirla intelligenza sensibile e a
questa capacità possiamo dare una
responsabilità quella di essere in
unione di cercare un'unione non quello
che ci divide Quindi come facciamo in
modo che le intelligenze artificiali
possano effettivamente essere uno
strumento che sia al servizio dell'uomo
e non di cui siamo asserviti di cui
siamo
assoggettati
sono le aziende Secondo voi a gestire le
risorse umane o sono le persone a
gestire le risorse aziendali Ecco perché
possiamo iniziare a parlare di
sensibilità umane e non di risorse umane
perché le risorse è qualcosa da spremere
qualcosa da
esaurire mentre la sensibilità è
rigenerare la mia proposta è di una
leadership sensibile una nuova strada In
effetti Pensateci il leader può stare in
fondo alla alla fila Eppure tutti gli
altri lungo il percorso sentono questa
questa cosa sentono questa energia Sono
Uniti sono connessi non serve essere
all'inizio non serve avere un modo di un
determinato tipo serve armonizzarsi
sentire in un determinato modo e voglio
provare a farlo con voi mi sto prendendo
un rischio altissimo e sto condividendo
però una responsabilità Provate a
sedervi un po'
diciamo sulla sedia o se volete anche in
piedi perché Adesso proviamo a fare
veramente una cosa insieme chiedo alla
regia di accendere le luci in
[Musica]
sala Allora potete dire qualsiasi vocale
che
volete e insieme possiamo provare a
creare un'armonia a lasciarci guidare da
questo suono che verrà da ognuno di
voi basta Semplicemente lasciarsi andare
e provare a dire una u una o una e una i
più forte più piano
proviamo
[Musica]
Proviamo
bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vai
Andiamo
[Applauso]
bene più
forte
andiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Sì bravo
Carlo
assumiamo possiamo abbassare le
luci quello che abbiamo vissuto adesso è
stato un
momento non di transizione ma
trasformativo io ho i brividi veramente
E perché è questo quello che possiamo
far accadere anche nel lavoro Possiamo
cominciare a dire perché non sentirsi in
paradiso nel lavoro lo so che Sembra
un'utopia
ma mi ha sempre affascinato questa
ricerca delle parole e io credevo da
piccolo che Universo significasse
proprio verso l'unione cioè indirizzati
verso l'unione non separati Come fanno
le macchine zero o uno Ma uniti Come ci
siamo uniti adesso e E come si fa si fa
partendo da una frequenza si fa partendo
dalla dell'ascolto relazionale un
ascolto che non sempe non è
semplicemente attivo perché l'ascolto è
attivo per definizione ma è un ascolto
che va verso l'altro io mi interesso a
te ti chiedo come stai Vengo verso di te
e non è una cosa che succede spesso
interessarsi Infatti si parla tanto di
insegnamento lasciare il segno si parla
altrettanto di formazione di formare
mentre possiamo educarci
exducere
Arci e poi l'energia se non c'era lo
spazio oggi in questo teatro non avremmo
sentito la musica non avremmo sentito le
voci non avremmo sentito le storie
quindi l'energia significa anche dare
spazio all'altro non riempire tutto
perché se io riempio tutto e metto un
seme difficilmente quello nascerà e da
ultimo le connessioni Che significa
proprio sentire insieme essere insieme
mettersi in una condizione del non dare
istruzioni ma dividere
intenzioni io l'ho imparato tante volte
anche oggi e qui ero in Africa quando mi
avevano dato due compiti Il primo era di
montare dei parafulmini dice Tu fai
l'ingegnere informatico monta i
parafulmini e il secondo era di fare un
coro con i bambini e ad tu sei musicista
fai il coro e io li ho falliti entrambi
perché facevamo le riunioni Per montare
i parafulmini e tutte le sere si parlava
in dialetto africano io non capivo
chiedevo al capovillaggio Dio ma che
cos'è Che vi dite tutte le sere e i
parafulmini non li stiamo
montando non so mi rispondeva cose che
non riuscivo a capire e dopodiché io
iniziai a vedere che effettivamente
tutte le sere c'era questo movimento e
dico Ma perché vi trovate e lui mi
rispose Per stare insieme Quando montam
i parafulmini fu bellissimo perché c'era
stato tutto quel quell'essere insieme
Quello stare insieme che non era
semplicemente svolgere un compito ma era
proprio dare senso a quello che si fa e
con il coro uguale Io ero partito dicevo
Ah io sono musicista ho fatto il
Conservatorio dirigo già cori gospel e
ho diretto anche con Gianni
Morandi no pensavo che il suono fosse la
frequenza con cui intonare quel coro ma
in Africa non c'è un sistema Tonale c'è
un sistema ritmico quindi ho dovuto
cambiare la modalità è imparare dai
bambini come creare quel coro e ho
imparato tantissimo ho imparato a uscire
dagli schemi ad uscire dalla scatola a
risolvere questa crisi energetica quindi
la leadership
sensibile voglio dirvi che è sentire con
l'altro insieme all'altro dove l'altro
non è accessorio non è lì e quindi noi
possiamo essere in un determinato modo
verso di lui o verso di lei ma siamo
proprio insieme perché gli abbiamo dato
spazio gli abbiamo dato una frequenza e
gli abbiamo dato un un energia e siamo
connessi quindi il leader sensibile non
ha quasi mai ragione perché va alla
ricerca della verità perché ha una
postura verso la verità perché non sa
quello che succederà se io programmo una
macchina da ingegnere so che succederà
probabilmente quello che ho programmato
mentre quando incontro le persone non lo
so quello che
accadrà e quindi la sensibilità è questa
porta verso la nostra coscienza e verso
la nostra autocoscienza è una porta
bellissima che ci fa intravedere
il paradiso in questa immagine che ho
scoperto essere qui vicino alla
biblioteca Marciana a
Venezia
Beatrice con una mano indica il sole con
l'altra lo fa scivolare verso Dante
perché Dante ha potuto scrivere quel
Paradiso che la Divina Commedia proprio
uscendo fuori da sé verso l'amore di
Bice che conobbe a 9 anni e e dice
questa cosa che leggo perché il sommo
Poe
va letto così la mia memoria si ricorda
cheio feci riguardando nei begli occhi
onde a pigliarmi fece amor la
corda sentite due volte la parola
ricorda il ricordo è il ritornare al
cuore fare un viaggio non è un sentire
del cervello Ma è un sentire in modo
complesso un sentire in modo
è questo quello che ci dobbiamo curare
ed è questo che forse ci collega di più
agli altri esseri umani alla natura alla
tecnologia ci unisce con una porta verso
il
paradiso
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
i